so there will be a war or not yes it will be but
only in two cases
if direct aggression is committed against Belarus
if a hot war is unleashed against our war in Belarus
and the second moment is
when there will be a war and the Belarusian will
participate in it if our ally the
Russian Federation
is directly attacked by
such  aggression will be committed against the
territory of the Russian Federation, the
basis for this is our allied agreement,
I want to note to the collective West they have
a very important question whether there will be troops
on the territory of Belarus
if aggression is committed against our country,
there will be hundreds of thousands of Russian troops
who, hundreds of thousands of Belarusians, will
defend this sacred  earth
[applause]
everyone just died all the loads
came to my head let's go from dusty rice not
wise positive core finish
cheaper our genoa
our lines and close
skis invade to die I'll worry
about okinawa villages salads with my healthy
psyche
[music]